Let me start a different place first and
then come through exactly what you want.
Um,
I was born in 1933 is that Adolf Hitler
was being elected,
the chancellor of Germany and some of my
earliest images is that young lad in the
movie theaters in the 19 forties was
really the opening of the concentration
camps by allied troops.
And then more and more as the weeks went
on,
film became available and we could say
these bodies being heaved like sacks of
earth or something like that up on the
trucks,
off the trucks.
And,
and,
um,
uh,
I,
that frightened me a bit when I was
young,
but it also impressed me that he had a
life could be a lot more meaningless
than we think it is.
A not nearly so comfortable.
Who of those people thought a year
before that they would be so treated?
I'm 100 million people in Europe alone.
I lost their lives by violence in the
20th century.
So when I read Haig only said history is
a butcher's bench chair.
Sure sounded true to me.
So,
um,
I'm,
you know,
I,
this,
this sort of sense of the possibility of
darkness and chaos and meaninglessness
and a
cruelty and barbarity at the heart of
things that seemed always to be alive in
my conscience.
Uh,
you know,
I don't remember a time when it,
when it hasn't been there.
Um,
and then I studied for a long time to
become a priest and I,
you know,
spent more than a decade in a monastery
is too strong a word because it's a more
modern now the order of the holy cross
fathers,
little bit like the Jesuit,
they teach it,
he run Notre Dame and Stone Hill
College,
my alma mater and so forth.
But we used to pray,
we admitted our regular schedule,
regular hours of the day,
a long day.
But,
um,
we,
we hit about four hours or more set
aside for prayer,
much of it together,
much of it private.
I'm alone.
And,
and there are often days and weeks where
I just didn't have any feeling for God
at all.
When you,
when I,
you know,
I,
I did so much doubt.
But nonetheless,
I did wonder sometimes whether all this
is a fraud or a,
you know,
am I kidding myself or deceiving myself,
but I learned that,
that this is a pretty common theme and,
and you should be,
you should be glad that these adult
moments and they're learn too
well.
What do you do?
I love the text of St John's letter m
where he says,
how do you know that you love God and
either you wouldn't be in a seminary or
a kind of,
and if you didn't think you love God,
but how do you know?
Um,
it's not enough just to say that.
And he said by this,
do you know if you love God,
if you have love for one another.
And so the moments of darkness ought to
lead you to be more kind and receptive
to others,
especially the ones that get on your
nerves.
Uh,
especially the ones that are hard to
deal with the gods in them too.
After all.
And,
and I say that just as a way of
negotiating the darkness.
It's not that you suddenly feel lighter
constellation,
but this seems like the North Star,
this seems like the right,
the True Path and some favorite saints
in mind.
Carmelites mostly not mother Theresa,
but St Theresa of Louisiana's and Teresa
of Avila,
um,
live through this darkness were
marvelous books about it and
guidebooks homeless if you want.
And I think they're onto something real
and deep and into,
and the Inter religious,
you know,
you find in every religion you find the
deepest people understand this very well
and can talk about it very well.
The more shallow people makes them
nervous,
but I religion that intends to be
universal.
It is meant to be universal as in
different ways that Judaism and
Christianity or,
um,
has got to be a shallow enough for ants
to wade through and deep enough to drown
giraffes,
if you know what I mean.
It's gotTa have room for all types.